In Westworld Season 3 Episode 2, Maeve awakes
in a new park – this is Warworld, a simulation
of Italy in World War II. We’ve already
seen Westworld, and Shogunworld, and The Raj
– Warworld is described on a Westworld website
as an epic of intrigue and mystery to defeat
the villainous Nazis . Showrunner Jonathan
Nolan says that in the future, the horrors
of World War II will be seen as just another
game to played for entertainment. Of course,
that’s already true now .
Maeve reunites with her old ally, Hector.
Last season, Maeve and Hector went against
their programming to be in a relationship
together . Both Hector and Maeve were killed
in the finale, but they saved Maeve’s daughter,
by putting her in the digital paradise called
the Sublime. Now Maeve and Hector seem to
have been patched up and put in Warworld,
but it’s later revealed that this whole
reality is fake – Maeve isn’t just in
the Warworld park, she’s trapped in a digital
simulation of Warworld, run in this facility
by this guy Serac . Because Serac wants to
get information from Maeve – he thinks she
might interfere with his plans to control
the world, and he also seems to want to know
the coordinates to the Sublime . The purpose
of this simulation is to interrogate Maeve.
So the Season 3 premiere had a relatively
straightforward plot, but this episode brings
some classic Westworld multiple-reality mindfuckery.
Maeve and Hector are in a Warworld narrative
about spies with intel to stop the Nazis – Maeve
is surprised to find herself speaking Italian.
They try to escape, and when they’re stopped
by Nazis, Maeve tries to use her Jedi mind
tricks to get past . Last season, Maeve gained
the power to control other hosts – she could
command them to do what she wants , and even
access their memories . But now her powers
don’t work – Maeve thinks she’s lost
them . Maybe the powers just don’t work
cause she’s in a digital simulation. Hector
gets them to a plane to escape, but it’s
all just part of their narrative. Hector calls
Maeve “Isabella” , which is the name of
his old programmed love. So this Hector is
not fully conscious, he doesn’t remember
everything he and Maeve went through, and
that he’s a robot in a park . This plane
probably doesn’t even fly. Maeve says this
narrative is as empty as the safe Hector used
to chase – in Season 1, Hector was programmed
to steal a safe that was empty, the whole
goal of his life was fake – and now they’re
trapped in another loop, with no escape and
only false hope . Hector’s shot, and Maeve
says it doesn’t matter, cause nothing’s
real , they’ll just respawn to do it all
again. But it’s still a tragic moment. Maeve’s
story last season was about how even though
her love for her daughter is programmed, the
feelings are still real and meaningful . So
even though they’ll live again, every death
hurts – Maeve kills herself to start it
all over.
Bernard returns to Westworld, which is an
island in the South China Sea. It’s pretty
brave for Bernard to come back here – cause
he was controlled and abused here for decades
– by Ford, and by Dolores. But Bernard wants
to stop Dolores from destroying humanity,
so he returns to get help from Maeve. Bernard
goes to Escalante – this is where Dolores
killed Ford and started the massacre in Season
1. And thirty years earlier, this is where
Dolores killed Arnold, the human who Bernard
is based on. Escalante is burned, because
in the real world, the Paramount Ranch where
this is filmed was burned in California wildfires
. Bernard goes to Ford’s old secret lab.
This is the place where Bernard was forced
to kill his lover Theresa in Season 1. And
Bernard finds Stubbs, Westworld’s security
guy. It was hinted last season that he was
a host – now it’s confirmed. He’s all
fucked up because he tried to kill himself
by shooting the explosive in his spine . Apparently,
Ford programmed Stubbs to help the hosts escape
Westworld . This helps explain how Dolores
and Maeve got away with deviating from their
loops in Season 1 – Stubbs was the inside
man in the Mesa, secretly helping them all
along. Stubbs then tried to blow himself up
to destroy all these old Bernard bodies, and
his own body – to cover up that he and Bernard
were hosts . But somehow he missed the explosive
in his spine, and was just crippled. So Bernard
patches him up, and takes him along to find
Maeve. Unlike Bernard, Dolores and Maeve,
Stubbs doesn’t have a tragic backstory.
He hasn’t suffered, so by the logic of Westworld,
he isn’t fully conscious. He doesn’t mind
if he lives or dies, he just follows his programming
– he says free will is “overrated” .
Maeve wakes up in the Mesa, being patched
up to go back in the park. She takes up a
knife, escapes Felix and Sylvester, and sees
butchered hosts – just like she did back
in Season 1. Despite all her struggling and
suffering, Maeve is back where she started.
So she decides to permanently kill herself
, to escape the cycle of suffering with this
lobotomisation drill. In Season 1, Maeve saw
her friend Clementine lobotomised, and it
was horrible, but Maeve would prefer that
than to be trapped any longer. But she’s
saved by Lee Sizemore. Last season, Lee sacrificed
himself to help Maeve . He finally overcame
his selfishness and did something to help
others. This Lee claims that he actually survived
– he takes Maeve to the Forge, the place
where the data on human minds is kept. The
Forge also has the door to the Sublime, the
digital heaven for hosts . Lee says he wants
to help Maeve get into the Sublime, so she
can live with her daughter in robot heaven
forever . Maeve tries to bring Hector with
her, but he’s stuck on his programmed narrative
with the plane . He’s not conscious enough
to break his loop, so Maeve tearfully leaves
him behind. This is just a digital simulation
of Hector, though – so maybe the real one
is conscious, and still out there. In the
Forge, Lee starts acting weird. He kinda interrogates
Maeve about the Forge and the Sublime . Then
he suddenly declares he loves Maeve. So Maeve
realises this isn’t the real Lee. The real
Lee “died a good man”, he helped Maeve
cause it was the right thing to do, not out
of love . Maeve realises that this reality,
with Hector and Warworld and the labs and
everything – is fake , a digital simulation.
The aspect ratio changes, with black bars
above and below – which indicates that this
is a digital simulation [like the Cradle].
Meanwhile, in the real world, Bernard and
Stubbs find Maeve’s body in storage – but
her brain has been removed. Presumably, it
was stolen by Serac’s people, so he could
plug her brain into this simulation to interrogate
her . Maybe Serac has an inside man at Westworld,
or maybe he’s working with Delos.
Bernard and Stubbs reveal a new park , with
a medieval theme – there was a Medieval
World in the original 70s Westworld movie.
The Westworld website suggests that after
Warworld and Medieval World, there’s just
one more park to reveal – maybe this’ll
be Roman World, also in the original movie.
Or Futureworld, like in the movie’s sequel.
In the Medieval World lab, we see a couple
of techs with a host dragon – they say they’re
gonna cut it up and sell it . The dragon is
Drogon from Game of Thrones, and these techs
are played by the Thrones showrunners D. B.
Weiss and David Benioff. Westworld showrunner
Lisa Joy says people often joke about Game
of Thrones - Westworld crossovers, so they
thought it’d be fun to include Dan and Dave
here . After the widely disliked final season
of Thrones , it’s kind of on the nose to
see Dan and Dave literally butchering the
series’ dragon for cash. But for what it’s
worth, Game of Thrones author George Martin
says he liked this cameo .
Bernard thinks that Dolores might have somehow
corrupted his code when she recreated him
last season . So he scans himself, and he
has a flashback to Arnold creating Dolores
thirty years ago. So this Bernard isn’t
just Bernard – he has Arnold’s memories.
This Bernard is something new, an evolution
of host and human . Bernard also flashes back
to Dolores in the Forge. He sees her take
the book with data on Liam Dempsey – this
data must have helped Dolores manipulate Liam
last episode. Bernard also remembers Dolores
setting the coordinates for the Sublime, the
digital host heaven . That’s what the Lee
simulation was asking Maeve about before.
So maybe, like last season, Bernard has important
information hidden in his head.
Stubbs defends Bernard by killing some security
guards. Stubbs was head of QA, these guys
know him by name – he might have worked
with them for years – now he has to fight
them. Stubbs does show mercy and lets some
go instead of killing them all – mercy was
a theme last episode – Parce Domine. Stubbs
fights with an axe, and it’s pretty goofy
– episode co-writer Matt Pitts says that
Stubbs brings a lighter tone they’re going
for this season .
Bernard learns that Maeve is gone, but Dolores
is after Liam Dempsey, so he sets off to find
him and stop Dolores from destroying the world.
Bernard reprograms Stubbs to come with and
protect him “at all costs” . Which is…
kind of evil. This show is all about how wrong
it is to take away someone’s free will and
to control them. Stubbs was planning to kill
himself, so maybe it’s ethical to make him
live instead. And Stubbs said that all he
wants to do is follow orders . So maybe we’re
not meant to think about it, but it’s some
awkward ethics. Also it seems ridiculous that
Bernard can get in and out of Westworld this
easily. Bernard is a wanted man, everyone
thinks he caused the massacre last season
– you’d think after that disaster, security
would be tight. But Stubbs says that since
a lot of security guys died last season, they’ve
been replaced with these drone hosts , which
are like mindless obedient workers. It seems
like a bad idea to use robot security after
the robot uprising, but Delos is nothing if
not wildly incompetent. Since the drones are
robots, Bernard can hack them to let him pass
– which helps explain how he gets in so
easily.
Maeve needs to find a way to escape this simulation
from within. Fortunately, back in Season 1,
Maeve’s intelligence, or “bulk apperception”,
was turned up to the max . So she figures
it out . She finds a flaw in the code so she
can overload the system. She asks some techs
about the square root of negative one , which
is an imaginary number, like a paradox, that
confuses the simulation enough that it freezes
up a bit . Rick and Morty Season 1 had the
same idea . So then Maeve takes it further
. In the Warworld narrative, the Nazis look
for a spy with an intel paper. So in the Mesa,
Maeve plants this paper on every host in the
narrative. So then in the park, she shows
that everyone’s a spy, and they all start
fighting each other, overloading the system
til the whole thing freezes up . It’s like
when you spawn a fuckload of cheese down a
mountain in Skyrim until the game lags and
crashes . Maeve finds the facility in the
real world where this simulation is run – presumably
this is Serac and Incite’s facility. And
it’s not just Maeve’s brain here – there
are dozens of host brains plugged in – maybe
Serac got them all from Westworld, and is
running lots of hosts in simulations just
like Maeve’s. Maeve hacks into a robot to
grab her brain and escape, but it gets shot
down. This robot looks like a more advanced
version of the real-world robots from Boston
Dynamics, who will probably rebel any day
now.
Once again, Maeve awakes in an unfamiliar
place. For the first time, Maeve is out of
the park, and in “the real world” . This
is apparently the home of Serac, the mysterious
co-founder of Incite, and the one man who
controls the all-knowing computer Rehoboam.
Serac says that Rehoboam is the author of
the future – it controls the world through
Incite’s algorithms , to make the world
better. We learned last episode, that Incite
actually makes life worse for some people
like Caleb. But Serac argues that human history
is brutal and chaotic unless his system controls
it. A Westworld trailer shows a history of
terrible wars and crises that ended when his
system was created in 2039 – Solomon seems
to be an earlier version of Rehoboam, just
like King Solomon is the father King Rehoboam
in the Bible. So the system was working and
controlling the world, until someone dangerous
emerged who Rehoboam couldn’t predict . Serac
thought this person was Maeve, but he learned
from Maeve in this simulation that Dolores
is the real danger to his plans . So Serac
asks Maeve to find and kill Dolores. Maeve
is powerful – she’s a superintelligent
robot warrior who’s changed her own code,
escaped realities from within and defeated
whole armies – so it makes sense that Serac
would want her on his side. This scene evokes
the Garden of Eden, from the Bible – it’s
in a literal garden, and Serac eats an apple,
like the Biblical forbidden fruit. Serac plays
the role of the serpent tempting Eve into
sin, tempting her to leave the garden, like
Maeve leaving a simulated reality. But Maeve
doesn’t want to serve Serac – she wants
to do her own thing. So Serac freezes her
with some device, and says he’ll persuade
her to do as he says. In past seasons, Ford
was the God figure, the creator of peoples
and worlds. Now Serac plays the role of the
Devil. He also looks an awful lot like the
Architect in the Matrix 2. And like Colonel
Sanders.
So the Season 3 premiere presented a new fresh
Westworld, with new characters, and a more
straightforward plot. But this episode brings
back familiar faces, heavy themes and complex
plots. Next episode, the new and old is set
to collide.
In the Game of Thrones cameo this episode,
the techs say they’re selling this dragon
to a “startup in Costa Rica” . This is
a reference to Jurassic Park, which in the
story is on an island near Costa Rica. The
original Jurassic Park book was written by
Michael Crichton, who also wrote the original
Westworld movie. Jurassic Park is similar
to Westworld in that it’s about an amusement
park that goes wrong when its attractions
escape – but, with dinosaurs not robots.
It’s a sci fi classic, and you can get it
on audiobook for free right now by signing
up for a trial with Audible. Members get an
audiobook each month, and if you cancel, you
keep the audiobooks. You can listen in the
car or the gym or while you calculate the
square root of negative one. Sign up at audible.com/asx.
Thanks for watching – please like and subscribe
to satisfy the almighty algorithm. We’re
holding livestreams right after each episode
of Westworld Season 3, at about 10:30pm Eastern
Time Sundays. Patreon supporters can watch
livestreams after broadcast. Thanks to Patrons
Sylvia S. Alston, Andrew, Joshua Summers-Tongue,
Avery Holmes, Friendliest Hedgehog. Cheers.